I understand that on the show james Van
Der Beek
we all remember starting Dawson's Creek
he plays himself on the shot he plays
james van der beek yeah he plays like a
weird like narcissistic monster version
of himself in real life is very nice and
then I actually live in his old house
how did that happen I was in New York
and the show got picked up thank you God
and he I sent a frantic emails to
everyone in my address book saying I
need a place to live and he wrote back
is it Kristen it's all good I have a
place and it's great it's got good vibes
and I know because I just moved out of
it so I moved in and I have a little dog
and my my welcome gift was a bottle of
wolf urine pee what wolf urine well yeah
just urine his pee so that the Coyotes
don't eat my dog wait what yeah so I
he gave me wolfy so you let you up in
the hill somewhere yeah yeah okay I'll
get the exact address later but you uh
you see you live up in the hills and and
and there's a lot of coyotes so many and
they prey on dogs and so this is what
you're supposed to do yeah you sprinkle
it around your house and you put it in
the it's like brown and horrible in the
yard not around the house you know so
why are you walk your honey in your
house spreading wolf dirt
squirting it everywhere it's it's so
disgusting it's a really dark brown it
scares away the Coyotes maybe my friends
what does it smell like does it smell
like urine yeah dude it's disgusting the
poop experts jumping in
love it
you remain completely silent - now
what's this I'm fine this appalling that
I mean I didn't know first of all I mean
that's something that people really do
does it work so so wolves come down I
mean how does it keep the wolf away
coyotes Oh coyotes are scared of wolves
yes oh ok now I'm getting it I'm getting
it so they like if their territory is
marked and the Coyotes won't come I've
seen them like in my back porch I've
seen three at a time they're so scary
they cannot eat my little dog no and
they're just they're just hanging around
they know he's are back there they're
like snapping their fingers
oh we're waiting for you
and then they approach but then this is
they just get close they like Oh urine
and they're out the door
exactly I'm not getting since I've had
the wolf urine a single coyote no I do a
commercial for them do you think there's
a money you just did this stuff sounds
fantastic where can I get some
I'm so embarrassed no don't be you trust
me this is the right show for this
discussion this is what we I'm now
interested in the harvesting yeah oh
they're getting it how do you get the
wolf to pee into the can
McCann jar or whatever it is freak if I
peed in a jar and wrote wolf on it
[Music]
[Applause]
we now need a thorough investigation we
need to know you got to come back and
you've got to bring james van der beek
and you've got to bring the wall who
really has to go we are gonna solve all
these matters